if you're watching in the UK you may
want to look away now petrol in America
below $2 a gallon
that's little more than 30 pence a litre
leaving drivers in Dallas delighted at
the pumps it's excellent
I do most of my work Drive so having a
dish cheap brings down costs for my
customers it's just wonderful for me
just that Christmas song I just noticed
it that is $1.99 I cannot believe that
loving it I mean they can drive a whole
lot more and plan a vacation this summer
to understand what's going on with oil
prices we went to West Texas for the
last five years
they've ridden one of the biggest oil
booms in history here of course Paul
Kenworthy owns ten oil wells tapping the
Permian Basin we are pumping out light
sweet West Texas Intermediate crude oil
how much is their care worth less than
it was before what they call Black
Friday when the price just plummeted
since June from say $95 down to $55 so
you know you can see it's what 40-plus
percent less so that's worth about forty
percent less than it was would have been
a few weeks ago correct and how does it
make you feel poor
paulla seen all prices rise and plunge
before but when OPEC refused to cut
production came as a shock to many here
even if people understand what the oil
cartels up to to use a line from The
Godfather it's a business it's not
personal they are trying to maintain a
market share and they're going to do
what it takes to maintain that market
share so it's a price war the affect of
it is a price war an OPEC us all of
price war threatens the drillers and
those depending on their business oil
equipment supplier Pat Kirby says people
are bracing themselves for what could be
on its way I know some people that spend
a lot of money private jets and so forth
you know hopefully they've been sucking
cash away as well good times never roll
forever
sometimes the gravy train does get
derailed making it harder for America's
oil industry is the knowledge it's
become a victim of its own success one
of the reasons for all prices plummeting
has been OPEX activities it's also
biggest demand for oil in Europe and
Asia has been going down but a lot of it
has to do with this fracking in America
and the huge increase in oil production
here as a result from the air the extent
of fracking is staggering until a few
years ago there were hardly any wells in
this stretch of West Texas in the
citadel's of the oil industry in Dallas
they're pondering multi-billion dollar
questions how long will this go on for
and how low can the old price go if it
were to rebound let's say in the first
half of 2015 up to 65 or $70 a barrel
I think on balance it will help the
recovery if it were to drop further I
think it'll harm the recovery so there's
a lot at stake here not just for America
but for the rest of the world there is a
lot of at stake for the rest of the
world
America's recovery has been driven in
part by its oil boom lower prices will
help that but up to a point if they fall
too low the US oil industry enters a
Twilight Zone and with it America's
economy and ours too Domenic Waghorn Sky
News Dallas Texas